turbulence is moving the airplane when  you're going through this turbulence  okay okay and the airplane has an  airfoil that is responding to the moving  air I'm with you okay if you are in that  airplane but you're not attached to the  airplane uh-huh then the airplane can  move around you that's right so if  you're not attached to the plane the  plane can drop yes faster than your body  will respond and you will snap your neck  on the ceiling of the plane that's right  so that's why when they enter turbulence  the pilot gets on and said uh ladies and  gentlemen of the plane  is your captain speaking just want to  let you know that we're in for a little  bit of a bumpy ride ahead uh well so  nothing to be worried about but if you  do believe in God now's your time